je vous le disais en titre l'horizon
s'assombrit encore un peu plus pour les
restaurateurs la réouverture de leur
établissement ne se fera sans doute pas
avant plusieurs semaines
alors après avoir tout tenté pour
maintenir une activité bien pour
certains l'envi n'est plus là vous voyez
ce reportage de romain delville dans un
restaurant tourangeaux en mars
cela fera deux ans que le petit
michettes ouvert enfin façon de parler
léa et antoine ont mis toute leur
énergie dans leurs restaurants ont fait
les plats à emporter pendant les
confinements mener des initiatives
communes avec d'autres restaurateurs
font dépôt de légumes avec leur
maraîchers fournisseurs mais là tout est
arrêté alors que la perspective de
rouvrir le 20 janvier n'est même plus à
l'ordre du jour on se demande en fait on
se dit est ce que cette situation
finalement c'est la normalité
on a l'impression qu'en fait le
resteront dans cet état c'est normal
annoncé ces jeux ce stade est passé quoi
on se dit bah en fait le restaurant
comme ça il sait restants qui est comme
ça qui doit être et c'est un peu
démoralisant cette attente qui s'allonge
cette absence de perspective a des
conséquences morales et financières pour
le jeune couple les frais s'accumulent
le loyer l'électricité la matière
première et face aux dépenses pas de
recettes dont le livre de contes
moi je suis au chômage un créatrice
d'entreprise donc je touche encore mon
chômage jusqu'à ce qu'on puisse se
verser un salaire en fait tout
simplement donc un salaire d'assedic
pour vivre à trois de 1100 euros et donc
en fait
antoine du coup se rémunérer juste avec
le restaurant est encore très peu avec
cette première année d'entreprise ce
était une création qui a pas de raison
qu'on se sorte des mille et des cents
fans comme n'importe quel entrepreneur
qui science des initiatives plein la
tête ces restaurateurs veulent juste
vivre de leur métier passion ce week-end
ils proposeront des galettes des rois à
emporter